oh hey i was just playing with my webby
before we dive into today's episode we
wanted to let you know that we now have
youtube memberships
support our show and receive awesome
perks click on the join button below
and choose your tier now back to our
regularly scheduled programming
[Music]
it's big it's blue
and it will tear you apart
well if you happen to drop into one of
its
giant earth-sized storms
as calm and breath-taking as it may
appear on the surface
neptune is a dangerous and violent place
so who's up for a field trip
why do neptune's rings clump in certain
areas
what treasures are hiding beneath its
atmosphere
and where could you survive the longest
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you fell into neptune
in 1989 nasa's voyager 2 spacecraft
whizzed past neptune five years later
we captured incredible images of this
planet
4.3 billion kilometers away from earth
with the hubble space telescope although
it might look like a fun place to bring
your yacht
neptune's oceans aren't quite the same
as the ones here on earth
about 80 percent of the planet is made
up of an
icy substance consisting of water
methane
and ammonia so
where exactly should we take the plunge
how about that big
dark spot over there let's not get ahead
of ourselves
that dark spot used to be a lot bigger
big enough to contain the entire earth
in fact
the great dark spot was one of neptune's
most
violent storms even though it is
dissipated
there are still several smaller storms
to contend with
before we dive in let's examine what is
just
outside of neptune like saturn
neptune has an intricate ring system but
not nearly as many rings there are at
least
five main rings including strange
clumps of dust called arcs
astronomers hypothesize that it's likely
neptune's moon galatia
and its gravitational disruption causing
this bizarre clumping effect
alongside galatia neptune has 13
other moons to our left you'll find its
most popular
moon triton known for its spectacular
ice volcanoes
based on neptune's tumultuous weather
it's probably best that you descend at
the northern hemisphere where the winds
are
tamer as a gas planet different parts of
neptune
rotate at varying speeds and depending
on your location
your length of day will vary at the
north pole
a day lasts 12 hours which
is a whole six hours shorter than a day
on the equator you gotta work smarter
not harder as they say unlike earth
neptune's atmosphere does not contain
any oxygen so
make sure to bring an ample supply to
breathe easy
with very little sunlight the brightest
neptune gets
is about the equivalent of a dim
twilight here on earth
so also be sure to pack a light source
or
some night vision goggles be prepared to
brace yourself
for wind speeds up to 550 meters
per second that's about five times
stronger than the harshest gusts here on
earth
and twice as fast as the speed of sound
as you pass through neptune's exosphere
its
outermost atmosphere your spacesuit will
experience
freezing cold temperatures as you drift
through the methane clouds
and it might reek a little
that was not me like in some places here
on earth
the weather can be a bit unpredictable
as you reach the thermosphere suddenly
the temperature rises
to about 477 degrees
and you'll encounter ammonia and
hydrogen sulfide clouds
astronomers agree that this bump in
temperature
could be a result of the atmosphere's
interaction with
ions in the planet's magnetic field
okay once you've made it through the
blistering heat of the thermosphere
you'll notice an increase in pressure in
the stratosphere
and the closer you get to the planet's
core
you'll notice things are starting to
heat up
fast as you make your way through all of
neptune's
3 000 kilometer thick hydrogen and
helium atmosphere
don't worry about smashing into the
ground
neptune doesn't have one per se
it's more of a slushy ice and water
layer
about 17 500 kilometers deep
if you were hoping for a spectacular
view
well sorry the atmosphere here
is too dense to see anything
as you finally pass through all the
slush you'll encounter
a super hot ocean and possibly some
hidden treasures
one of the consequences of the high
pressure and temperature on neptune
is that its carbon and hydrogen atoms
could separate
forcing isolated carbon atoms to be
squeezed
into diamond structures these would
likely sink to the planet's core but
could be as large as one meter in size
who knew neptune had so much bling
here in the core the temperature is
piping hot
about 7 000 degrees which is comparable
to the surface of the sun
realistically a mere human probably
couldn't survive this journey
but maybe a resilient space probe could
now that we've got our sea legs maybe we
could explore
jupiter next think you could handle it
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
[Music]
you